Élancourt 25660 habitants au 1er janvier
2020 et cette année trois listes en
course pour les municipales contre 4 en
2014 leur rassemblement national ayant
jeté l'éponge 35 sièges sont à pourvoir
dans cette commune et 10 élus
représenteront la ville au sein de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines liste investi
par la République en marche et l'encours
c'est vous se revendique avant tout
citoyenne à sa tête Michel Rossi c'est
sa première campagne municipale son
programme s'articule autour de trois
thèmes la consultation des élans
courtois le dynamisme de la ville et
l'écologie ce programme il est le fruit
déjà de tous les échanges qu'on a eu
avec une bonne partie de la population
pour nous quand on dit démocratie la
concertation elle démarre déjà pendant
la campagne on n'attend pas d'être élu
pour éventuellement démarrer une
concertation et l'humeur en 1996 réélu
dès le premier tour avec 60% des
suffrages en 2014 Jean-Michel fourgot se
regroupe sur sa liste aller et l'encours
des candidats allant de la droite au
centre gauche il souhaite poursuivre les
dossiers et lancés durant ces dernières
années la préparation des Jeux
Olympiques piscine intercommunale ou
encore projets éducatifs entre autres je
pense qu'elle est en cours joue dans les
équipes gagnantes et du département et
dans Paris Saclay vous le savez et même
d'une façon générale dans la France
puisque plusieurs fois et souvent
Élancourt et cité quand même modèle je
rappelle qu'on a 35 prises qui est assez
rare pour une ville comme Élancourt
désignée tête de liste lors d'une
élection sans candidat au sein d'un
collectif citoyen et associatif
Catherine perrotin@tm mène sa première
campagne municipale épaulé par un binôme
soutenu par l'ensemble des formations de
gauche à l'entend réinventer et
l'encours c'est d'ailleurs le nom de sa
liste nous voulons que les gens dans
leur quartier puissent exprimer leurs
besoins ensuite qu'on nous entendions la
façon dont ils veulent que nous
répondions à ses besoins et ensuite que
nous décidions avec eux ce que nous
allons faire pour leur quartier en 2014
959 électeurs s'étaient rendus aux urnes
en cours